I dated another girl in Portland she was
like one of the first suicide girls like
the OG respect
models um no but it didn't end up
happening like she was I was like I'm
talking to her at the date I'm like what
are you up to today and she's like oh
I've been icing down my [__] from all
the [__] I've been
doing and I'm
like I'm like cool I was writing some
jokes you
know and I'm like I don't know how to
take that I'm like is this a joke what
do you mean then we go back to her place
place and then we're kind of making out
and then I look over and I see an ice
pack and I'm like I'm out I'm out I got
to go an ice pack it's just out of sight
out of mind it's implied this hot ass
mentally ill woman with turquoise hair
is getting [__] down but now that it's
been made explicitly clear she got
[__] down to the point where she's
treating her [__] like it's LeBron
James knees after the
finals you're like you know what I'm out